Dividamos 3,771 / 8. Vamos a hacer una división
larga. Lo primero que haremos es preguntarnos
¿8 cabe en 3? Bueno, no, 8 no cabe en 3, así que
tomamos el siguiente dígito, y nos preguntamos:
¿el 8 cabe en 37? Por supuesto, 8 x 4 es 32, 8 x 5
es 40, aquí ya nos pasamos, entonces 8 cabe en 37
cuatro veces: 8 x 4 es 32, lo restamos y obtenemos
37 - 32, que es 5. Y sólo para que te des una idea
de lo que está pasando aquí, lo que realmente
estamos diciendo es ¿cuántas veces cabe 8 en
3,700? Y estamos diciendo que 8 cabe en 3,700 400
veces, el 4 está en la posición de las centenas,
y que 400 x 8 es 3,200, y luego, cuando
restamos 3,200 de 3,700 obtenemos 500.
Esto es lo que realmente está pasando aquí:
cuando decimos que 8 cabe en 37 cuatro veces,
realmente estamos diciendo que 8 cabe en 3,700 400
veces. Pero volvamos a la mecánica tradicional de
la división larga. Así que ahora tenemos que
ocuparnos de este 5 que, como ya mencioné,
está en la posición de las centenas, así que
realmente se trata de 500. Pero ahora veamos
el otro valor posicional, así que bajemos el 7 y
pensemos cuántas veces cabe 8 en 57. Y de nuevo,
lo que realmente estamos pensando es cuántas veces
cabe 8 en 570. Pero veamos: 8 en 57, 8 x 5 es 40,
8 x 6 es 48, 8 x 7 es 56 así que cabe siete
veces, 8 x 7 es 56, y ahora restamos de nuevo:
57 - 56 es 1. Y ahora veamos el otro valor
posicional: bajamos el 1 y ahora nos preguntamos
¿8 cabe en 11? Bueno, 8 cabe en 11 una vez: 1
x 8 es 8, y nos quedamos con, porque no tengo
más dígitos que bajar, 11 - 8 es 3, entonces 8
cabe en 3,771 471 veces, y el residuo aquí es 3.